it does not you're not required to have
a taxers license in order to return your
own uh make your own Federal Tax Returns
for example so the license to carry is
for Security Professionals to carry a
firearm in the performance of their
duties to serve the public it is not a
license to bear arms for the for one's
personal use this is well recognized law
since 1943 in Murdoch versus
Pennsylvania where the Supreme Court
says a state may not impose a charge for
the enjoyment of a right granted by the
Federal Constitution a person cannot be
compelled to purchase through a license
fee or a license T tax the privilege
freely granted by the
Constitution thus States like
Massachusetts intentionally misapply
these otherwise constitutional laws to
the injury and extraction of the
Americans within their borders and it is
this great evil we call the color of law
today and which the founders referred to
as acts of pretended legislation in a
jurisdiction foreign to our Constitution
and unacknowledged by our
laws
um we can't do anything to prevent
violations of the constitution in other
states but the state of New Hampshire
needs not unlawful unlawful actions of
other states and this legislation is
needed to Safeguard the rights of the
people of this state and to give notice
to other states that their illegal
practices shall not be aided or embedded
within our
borders um I'm ready for any question
that uh the legislators would like to
ask thank you thank you sir
um I understand this issue and I've seen
it happen I believe particularly
egregious State might be New Jersey I
think where people are often um run a
fou of this issue
um by traveling to an airport if they
happen to pick up their baggage and have
to leave they're automatically a felon
right um the the the question I have was
it sounds like you've done some research
on this how do we Square the circle of
article 4 section 1 that says full faith
and credit that part of the Constitution
that says we have to honor the court
rulings of other states um for this
reason you you honor sir um there are
actually two kinds of uh crimes that
that people don't generally know about
but it's it's derivable if you think
about it the first kind kind of kind of
crime is a common law crime that
involves an injured party and the second
crime is called a called a regulatory
crime and the Massachusetts judicial uh
Court uh has affirmed on several
occasions that quote in the context of a
statutory analysis the unlicensed
possession of a firearm itself is a
regulatory crime and now a regulatory
crime is by definition in enforced by
the Regulatory Agencies if you look at
the state's administrative procedure act
Mass general laws 30 Alpha section one
defines a regulations as rules adopted
by an agency to implement to enforce or
to uh interpret the law administered by
it the fact that these agencies are
not um made a party and not allowed to
be in the court so to
speak um makes this makes that uh a
violation of the state's administrative
procedure act their own State's
administrative procedure act where it
says licensing agency has quote solely
to determine whether the agency shall
Institute or recommend Institute
proceedings in a court and according to
their own declaratory judgment act at
231a Section
8 any proceeding which involves the
validity of a license the licensing
agency granting the privilege shall be
made a party and shall be entitled to be
heard now I can tell you this when I was
going to trial this the the the person
running the show the
magistrate did not allow the licensing
agency to come forth and um confer their
subject matter jurisdiction of the
licensing board now that would be
equivalent to me having a with my
medical license and the County
prosecutor Prosecuting me for a
violation of my of the Medical Practice
Act if they brought me into a County
Court they would have no subject matter
jurisdiction unless the medical board
who has uh who has been vested with that
subject matter expertise comes up to the
court and confers it to them so the to
the answer to your question is that it's
squares with uh Article 4 because there
was no court that was actually um
convened if we study this issue very
carefully what we have here is a lack of
subject matter jurisdiction before the
court and when that happens um we know
that it is a proceeding Quorum non
judice and um and a nullity under the
law it's uh many many statuto many many
cases law and statutes say that
including uh Federal rules civil
procedure number 12 and Mass general
laws uh under the criminal code as well
they must have subject matter
jurisdiction so your position is that we
wouldn't be bound by Article 4 because
the Court ruling wouldn't actually be a
Court ruling um within the meaning of
the law but if we're talking about
extradition orders so the the
extradition order would presumptively be
that you had been charged with a crime
in Massachusetts and you did not come to
Massachusetts to stand for that crime
and they asked for your extradition from
New Hampshire to Massachusetts is your
position that the order ordering you to
come stand before the court not uh in
your opinion binding under Article 4 or
just the procedure with which they wish
to try you on the um Firearms charge um
my position is that any any charge that
is without jurisdiction is without um
without due process and the state of New
Hampshire has a constitutional duty to
uphold not only Constitution but the
laws and the due process within its own
borders so in the very least I think a
person in that situation um should be
brought before or have an opportunity to
go before a New Hampshire judge and say
look here are the charges here's why
they don't have jurisdiction and here's
why I'm entitled uh to the protections
of this state and under the current laws
is it your opinion that you do not have
the right to fight
extradition um under the current laws
you've already been captured and you've
already been spent spent time possibly
weeks or months in jail so there's a
deprivation of Rights before any remedy
is
due more of a speedy um hearing yes
thank you any further questions from um
members yes representative sake thank
you and thank you for taking my question
I'm just curious do you currently live I
mean you're you're talking about charges
that happen in Massachusetts correct is
in your testimony do you live in New
Hampshire I do I've been a New Hampshire
resident since 200 Circa 4 or three or
something like
that representative
m can you tell us what the current
status is of your medical license uh my
medical license is clear and active in
New
Hampshire
followup has your medical license been
suspended in other states uh yes it has
starting in new not in new but
Massachusetts it
has followup followup but um medical
license is really not relevant to this
but go ahead it it's been fully
adjudicated in in New Hampshire and in
in other states in other jurisdictions
as well uh but it remains revoked in
Massachusetts um just interject the
medical license is often suspended
automatically is it not if you're
suspended in one state they have an
agreement where everyone does it and
then you have to go back and get them
all correct and and in this case uh New
Hampshire did do their adjudication and
they decided that I wasn't a problem
thank you for if you have another
question repres m
what was the reason for the suspension
of your
license um I'm not sure if that I see
that is relevant to to this case but it
had nothing to do with the practice of
medicine or any common law crime that's
good enough thank you representative
Reed U Mr chairman I don't see how that
line of questioning is relevant to um
the bill where being were discussed it
could have been if it was relative to
the crime he was going to be extrated
for but we've already explored it and
tked and answered um any further
questions
uh representative Pratt do you have a
question okay anyone else seeing no
further questions thank you very much
for your testimony sir thank you very
much sir I
was is there anyone else here wishing to
testify on this bill who has not yet
testified seeing none I close the public
hearing on HB 1035 and I open the public
hearing on hp1
1404 yes I'm
sorry oh I didn't realize we' went so
fast um I GA the S
huh the previous witness I closed the
hearing um we're going to just be in
recess for 10 minutes okay and you
can
10:00 I open the public hearing on HB
1404 and invite the um representative to
introduce this
bill good morning committee Jason Gard
representing Franklin Northfield marac
25 I think it'd be easiest to explain
what I was trying to go for with this
bill and let you guys decide if that hit
the mark or
not the problem in my mind is that there
are vindictive prosecutions or
prosecutions for crimes that aren't
truly crimes where the defendant does
not have the opportunity to actually go
before a jury of their peers to have
them
adjudicated
because certain personal examples during
the whole covid scare
planemic I was arrested for putting
anti-mask and vaccine stickers on and
around city hall in Manchester that case
was dropped but not after a long drawn
out period of harassment arrest and so
forth
but even if that case had proceeded to
trial I would have never been able to
actually go before members of the public
and explain my purpose in doing
so which I think has been Vindicated at
this point
but I just feel that that's a it's a
dangerous dangerous precedent to set
where people can be arrested for things
and because they're charged at a lower
level you never have the opportunity to
actually bring them before people other
than government officials as in judges
and then at that point this you don't
even have the ability to argue jury
nullification which I think is a key
fact because that allows you to say okay
I might have violated this so-called law
but at the same
time this law doesn't comport with the
Constitution or simply common sense and
so forth and that's the last paragraph
of this bill not withstanding any other
provision in this chapter any and all
courts shall accept the introduction by
the defendant of any evidence relevant
to his or her her pro- offered defense
even if such defense is not explicitly
recognized by law and particularly any
defense purported by the defendant to be
regarding a violation of the New
Hampshire
Constitution the defendant shall be
entitled to produce all proofs that may
be favorable to favorable to himself or
herself that the defendant believes to
be relevant to attempt to persuade the
jury to exercise Its Right of
nullification there are other
additional rushes with the law that I've
been involved in including being
arrested out front of the governor's
house well I'm sorry that was ticketed
fined if we had a candlelight visual
another individual was arrested just
during the co lockdown because the
governor was conducting business out of
his house State business so there was
protests held
there and again that charge was just
dropped but even if it had proceeded to
trial you don't have the opportunity to
actually explain what was going on and
letting the general public decide if
that was a
valid a valid
cause so that is the general gist of
what I was attempting to go with this
and that's also why on page
two
where you will be afforded to trial for
anything over $20 however there's caveat
in
that there will be a fee set at
$500 if the defendant is found guilty of
the initial charge and this is to offset
people taking every stupid little thing
to trial just to slow down the system
because I understand Justice is
important to move swiftly but at the
same time I don't think it should be
like McDonald's fast food I think you
need to kind of evaluate each case and
figure
out if this is demonstrating a larger
issue that needs to be
addressed instead of just kind of rubber
stamping everything and just pumping
people through the system so that is
that's basically where I was going with
it I'm not sure if it made the the the
point clear but I'm opening to any
questions try to clarify thank you
representative um so I I understand the
first principle that you should be um
allowed a jury trial for just about
everything I mean exceeding $20 the
question I have is is are you trying to
kind of get two bites at the Apple here
where you can go ahead and have a judge
you elect for a trial by a judge and
then if you don't like the outcome get a
jury trial on the same charge or or or
are you saying I should have the option
in the first instance to say I I'll go
with the judge or I want a jury I the
latter was what I was going for one of
the two but not and then say I don't
like this I want the jury now okay thank
you any further questions from the
members uh Mr uh representative
Muse I like the way you think with
numbers um so as I understand your bill
um a charge a defendant who actually l
loses a case would be charged an
additional $500 M but if defendant who's
exonerated would get $5,000 back yes the
intent is to keep the government from
Prosecuting people for phony
crimes you should not be getting
arrested with a Mis misdemeanor charge
putting a sticker on a garbage can in
Manchester that says you know don't get
vaxxed honestly if I knew now what I
knew you know yeah I wouldn't I would
put a million more stickers but
anyway would it um would it not make
more sense to say if you're exonerated
your attorney fee should be paid for
instead of just a blanket $5,000 check
to everybody the the problem is certain
people like the previous gentleman that
testified they're walking lawyers as it
is so say they yeah I I worry that
people that are actually skilled in the
law which I think we need to be more
more people to do so instead of just
giving wi doctor attorneys the power
over them um yeah that if that makes
sense trying to avoid that okay um
representative s thank you I have a
concern so if someone committed a
penalty that would the violation would
exceed $20 and they're then found guilty
by a jury you're saying they would need
to pay $500 but for people who may be
already of extremely limited
means wouldn't that punish them further
by giving them a penalty they couldn't
afford to pay well as current currently
they would just go before a judge so I
say just go for a judge roll the dice
and have
fun so for clarity if you just go with
the judge and you're found guilty you
don't get to 500 if you say I want to go
full jury trial and that's only the
crimes the the newer lower level of
crimes that you're proposing you'd have
to pay the $500 because you opted to
have the JY imp panel and everything
instead of just taking the judge yeah I
don't want people you know some of the
homeless people you're erating in public
drawn stuff out just for the hell you
know that's what I'm trying to avoid it
was more just to say I as as everyone
should understand by now I'm more on the
political kick of things where I think
that we need to be challenging some of
the violations of our rights more
aggressively and this is to Aid and
support that it's future further
testimony will
elucidate thank you
yeah see you no further questions thank
you for your
testimony um the chair calls Mr Staples
thank you
um I'm here to support this bill I was
arrested seven times through covid
couple times with Gart uh I was the one
who organized the candlelight vigil out
in front of suoo which many of you may
have seen there was a newspaper article
about malicious prosecution that six
people are suing um the estate of one of
the officers who wrote the tickets she
died suddenly very much likely from the
jab um and they're
suing Trooper dods who received guidance
from the attorney general at the time
which was Gordon
McDonald he's the one who coached these
State Police and town officers on how to
charge an arrest in how to enforce the
town ordinance that was created out of
thin air by Michael sonunu and if you
haven't seen all the videos about this I
have all the videos on this I have the
testimony from dods all on video
so I've also represented myself prosay
oh excuse
me
on all these cases it's found not guilty
on most of them some of the charges were
dropped the stickers on City Hall were
dropped I then went and put stickers on
before the charges were dropped I put
stickers on City Hall in uh I mean the
police station in
Manchester and they removable stickers
the officer testified that she peeled
them right off she didn't have to call
maintenance take them down or anything
and I was still found guilty and I was
not able to appeal denovo to a jury
trial which I would have been able to do
for any other crime right for violations
and Class B Mis meanors you're not
allowed to get that denovo thing so
that's already a thing to go from one to
the other the whole
$500 administrative fee or whatever that
is I don't know if that's necessary or
if that's too much um because currently
how it is you have to appeal direct to
the Supreme Court court and that process
is expensive it's you know most many
hundreds of dollars and is that is very
difficult I would have to agree with uh
rep selig with what she said on that um
and to touch on the
$5,000 for attorney fees that's also for
self-representation because you can seek
uh reasonable attorney fees for
self-representation right and that would
assure that people who do do that and
who do win these things like I said I've
had multiple victories
and not guilty verdicts on my prosay
defenses and then I've had some that um
you know I was found guilty like with
the woman who was arrested for saying
amen Tes grenell at the the executive
council meeting for the 72 million you
guys all remember that of course that
was orchestrated by governor shunu and
the state police to Target us for
shutting down the previous executive
council meeting okay I did nothing that
day I was found not guilty
on being arrested for allegedly saying
yeah to Teresa's amen was found not
guilty but then I was found guilty
behind the curtain once I was already in
handcuffs for protesting my arrest and
we have this the prosecution saying that
you can't protest your arrest there's
there's no statute there's no
constitutional right to protest your
arrest which is absolutely absurd okay
so I do agree with rep Gerard here with
these malicious prosecution that are
happening for simple things like filming
in court Candlelight vigil out in front
of the governor's
house um and saying
amen right um so I would have loved to
been able to have a jury trial on these
things as is insured to me by the state
constitution there's nowhere in the
State Constitution that says oh if it's
a small small violation or a minor crime
you don't get a jury trial so I would
say this would get us in line with the
state
constitution um you know maybe it needs
to be edited a little bit with the with
the fine thing or the administrative fee
but I think this is important to
recognize the overreach uh by the state
here and the
weaponization of these statutes and this
the the criminal mischief thing and
disorderly conduct catchall everything
is disorderly conduct my loud this I was
arrested in front of sununu's house for
asking the cop what he wanted me to stop
doing says stop if you don't stop you'll
be arrested if I don't stop what sir I'm
under arrest for asking if I don't stop
what and those cases are still I have to
file a rule 11 uh petition in the
Supreme Court because the two judges on
the two not the two guilties that I did
get the judges refuse to write a written
decision how am I supposed to file a
brief in the courts without a written
decision on the merits it needs to be
there rule 27A and the judges blatant oh
he doesn't understand rule 27A even
though it says right in there it has to
be a written decision so I digress a
little bit but I do agree with this I
think it would uh it would be you know
constitutional thank you representative
Reed thank you Mr chairman I understand
you know what when representative geard
are saying you know but my my confusion
comes where's the videotaping part fit
in you it's proof of all the
Tyranny that we've been dealing with
through covid in this fake lockdown okay
I have evidence of sonunu texting the
state police to organize our arrest it
has to do with the weaponization of the
government in the in the State Police by
politicians that's what it has to do
with I don't I don't know if that's what
she's is that what you're asking or were
you talking about if you want to see the
videos you can go to absolute Defiance
that's all right there no no I am
actually follow you on YouTube we saw um
what what she's asking you though is you
said arrested for videotaping in court I
think correct oh yeah so the federal
courthouse thing that's a federal thing
so it's a little bit different but there
is concurrent jurisdiction uh but there
in this in the Supreme Court I have a
whole playlist of audits that I did I
went there to cuz I got hung up on by
the clerk and I had to go there and I'm
filming and they're hitting the Panic
alarm because I'm I have this camera in
my hand and they got the state police
coming there and there is no law there
is a policy amongst all of the courts
that comes from Timothy Gus it is a
order a supreme court order it's not
even from a judge there's no docket
number on it it's from the clerk Timothy
gutus that says that we're not allowed
to film in the court even though we are
allowed to film in the court and all the
and they're they're prohibiting us from
filming in the public I think that bill
is coming up today right so I'll testify
more on that for sure definitely I see
thank you sorry thank
you see no further questions thank you
for your testimony thank you thanks is
anyone else wishing to testify on this
bill wasn't testified yet seeing none I
close the public hearing on
HB
1404 and open the public hearing on
hb1438 at oh there I am jumping the gun
again um 15 minute
recess
I just like rolling rolling rolling I
know I
wish
e
okay I'm opening the public hearing on
hb1
1438 morning
committee Jason Gard Franklin Northfield
marac
25 this bill is extremely
simple it simply prevents
whistleblowers from being harassed in
this
state
by state officials but also prohibiting
Federal officials from carrying out
basically black bagging and you know
extradition attempts against them my my
feeling is that if we have any desire to
return this government to
somewhat some stability at all I think
we need whistleblowers to feel that they
can come forward and bring forth the
truth of what's actually occurring
behind closed doors because that's how
we receive most of the most important
information I'm thinking Edward Snowden
Julian Assange many others who are
rotting in prison or have to flee to
Russia
um yeah I just just think that it's
important for people to realize that
there is a place they can go to Live
Free or Die state would be an excellent
choice where they can bring forth
evidence of corruption fraud everything
else before the people and then we can
try to to rectify it instead of having
these people fear for their lives and
their
livelihoods I'm yeah it's uh it's kind
of simple and I don't know I don't
really think there's much to say I just
think we need whistleblowers to come
forward and the best way to do that is
to have them know that they'll be safe
if they do so so take any
questions represent
Muse you've defined whistleblowers but I
know we already have a statute that
protects public employees who are
whistleblowers who exactly is this
statute designed to protect I'm more
thinking people that are bringing
evidence against the federal government
or other entities higher than that not
necessarily state level people but
people that people that have to escape
to Russia let's put it that way follow
followup your mic's Mike
Mike how exactly do the those folks
qualify uh as whistleblowers and aren't
whistleblowers people kind of on the
inside we're talking about people let's
say like Edward
Snowden so for example for clarity
someone who comes across some
information that could be embarrassing
to a public official and they wish to
share it you are saying they should be
given whistle Bo well traditionally what
we would call journalists the ones that
actually do journalism that produce
documents that publish documents that
the government may not want to have
released but they claim that they're
National Security Secrets it be at the
Pentagon papers back in the 70s or I
mean it's there's multiple examples but
it's just recently there's been some
attempt to claim that any government
documents that they don't want released
violate the Espionage Act of whatever
1914 or some nonsense you know what I
mean I'm trying to just eliminate all
that and just if you have the truth it
needs to come out because obviously the
government not doing what it's supposed
to be doing or we wouldn't have all the
problems that we have so that's kind of
where I'm going with this thank
you thank you representative I'm looking
at um paragraph two yes it says it would
be a classy felony for any civilian
state employee to no only cooperate or
assist with any attempt by law
enforcement to detain arrest or
prosecute a
whistleblower um it doesn't say detain
arrest or prosecute for what um so that
would make it a crime for someone to for
example uh be a witness against someone
if they committed a crime it's not
limited to just their whistleblowing
acts that they're protect it's it's kind
of broad I'm I'm just pointing that I
don't know if that was your intent but
no but I I mean what would be what would
stop a nefarious entity from just making
up a crime against somebody just to get
them out of the way because they are a
whistleblower no I I meant for example
let's say it says a civilian state
employee so say um our assistant and a
whistleblower was here and The
Whistleblower um assaulted somebody and
he witnessed it he would be unable to
assist in that prosecution because he
witnessed that crime I'm not saying that
they they um are going after them for
some other type of thing I'm saying he's
a direct witness he wouldn't be able to
testify if this were to become law it's
my reading of it I see what you're
saying it makes sense maybe something
along the lines of unless that IND
whistleblower was to commit a common law
offense
just so you don't have some kind of you
know tail light out or something so
thank you any further questions
representative n thank you Mr chair and
thanks for taking my question um line 10
it says um it is a class B felony for
any civilian state employee to harass
with aent intent to alarm any
whistleblower I was just wondering if
you could Define that a little more
clearly what it means to
alarm I I think more or less harassed to
the point where they don't want want to
go forth with what they're doing I you
know we can change it I'm open to
suggestions
thanks any further
questions seeing none thank you all
right thank you very much is there
anyone else anyone else wishing to
testify on this bill seeing none I close
the public hearing on hb1438 and we will
reconvene for HB
40445 at
for
e
in a public hearing on HB
1455 good morning once again Jason Gard
Franklin Northfield Marram
this
bill would provide that where the public
is allowed to videotape audio record and
so forth in any publicly accessible area
of any public building or on any public
land where in the state of New Hampshire
maintains either exclusive or concurrent
jurisdiction so that last part is
important so put that in your notes
so there's a penalty asso assciated with
this and it steps up if you do it
multiple times so the
reason exclusive or concurrent
jurisdiction is important is because
this bill is
specifically aimed towards the federal
court system
because somebody that will testify after
me has already done this at the state
with the within the state courts and
they're generally complying with the law
at this time there's some holdouts here
and there but RSA one
231 jurisdiction over lands
acquired States seated to the United
States jurisdiction is seated to the
United States of America over all lands
within the state now or Hereafter
exclusively owned by the United States
and used as sites for post offices
custom houses military air bases
military installations or other public
buildings provided that an accurate
description and plan of the lands so
owned and occupied verified by the oath
of some officer of the United States
having knowledge of all the facts shall
be filed with the secretary of this
state and provided further that this
secession I mean session I'm sorry is
upon the express condition that the
state of New Hampshire shall retain
concurrent
jurisdiction with the United States in
and over all such land so far as so far
that all civil and criminal process
issuing under the authority of this
state may be executed on the said lands
and in any building now or Hereafter
erected thereon in the same way and with
the same effect as if the statute had
not been enacted and that exclusive
jurisdiction shall revert to and revest
in this state whenever the lands shall
cease to be the property of the United
States
so let me back up a little bit recently
actually September 11th me and somebody
that'll testify after me were arrested
at the federal courthouse in conquer for
videotaping in the
lobby inside the lobby it even has a
plaque on there saying it's a public
building
but Department of Homeland Security
decided that that's not going to fly so
they they arrested US and charged us
under well it'll be discussed further
it's a CFR that has no penalty
associated with the whole thing is kind
of fishy
but I beforehand on the Friday before it
was a Monday but the Friday before we
spoke with DHS and kind of let him know
was going to go on you know I'm not
trying to surprise the cops the whole
point is to get arrested Civil
Disobedience 101 so explain to the cops
DHS I should say that state law another
state law for you obstructing government
Administration 642 colon one a person is
guilty of a misdemeanor if that person
uses intimidation actual or threatened
force or violence simulated legal
process or engages in any other unlawful
conduct with a purpose to hinder or
interfere with a public servant as
defined in RSA 640 col 2 performing or
purporting to perform an official
function or to retaliate for the
performance or purported performance of
such function and then in 642 to Define
public servant public servant means SE
uh s part two SE uh a public servant
means any officer or employee of the
state or any political subdivision
thereof including judges legislators
consultant jurors and other persons Etc
so I explained to them that I was
operating as such an individual and that
I had the right to record that because
New Hampshire has concurrent
jurisdiction within that building and
that is why I brought this bill forward
was to clarify that New Hampshire never
gave away their concurrent jurisdiction
and further I didn't submit this but we
can get this from the Secretary of State
I have a gold seal certificate the
federal government has never complied
with RSA
1231 so they even file the papers and so
you can even argue that they don't even
have we actually have exclusive you know
we don't we didn't even surrender that
aspect to it but the point being is the
bill gave back to the bill is to rectify
the situation where we have
supposed public buildings that are off
limits to people recording because
certain people as you'll hear further
later on if you have somebody that has
memory issues or any other kind of
developmental issues or whatever it may
be they may not be able to remember
everything that a judge tells them in a
court hearing I don't know if anybody's
gone to trial especially in federal
court things get weird fast a lot
happens so the ability to record and
document what is occurring is critical
to be able to preserve your rights
because if you don't raise something you
wave it and then you're pretty much up
the creek
the and well there's also the issue of
stenographers and hoping that the court
actually records what was said and done
and there's many anecdotal uh stories
about that not
occurring so that's the basic gist and
concept behind this is simply to
reestablish New Hampshire's concurrent
jurisdiction Within Federal well lands
that the federal government maintains
concurrent jurisdiction over not
exclusive and yeah so it's state
sovereignty issue as
well a second um so couple questions the
state um has concurrent jurisdiction and
uh according to what you're saying for
example with um military
installations the military clearly has
the ability to say okay you can't
videotape here National Security issues
who who do you think gets to decide then
which places are and are not a for
example I know the Supreme Court doesn't
allow videotapes that's why we have to
look at those sketches all the time so
who is the final Arbiter of what should
be a secure Zone and what not I assume
the homeland security saying this is a
security area for whatever purposes so
who would under this who would be able
to
decide I think it would have to just
revert back to common sense if a
building says it's a public building
I mean the whole idea of having trials
is so the public can see that Justice is
being carried out and to eliminate
vigilante ISM
so yeah
okay um representative um rhs thank you
Mr chairman I just need some
clarification from you representative or
is this is this specifically just
talking about you know cour houses or
would this also be you know like an
elementary school that's considered a
public
building I believe uh schools are
already covered under public buildings
and you can record there as far as I
understand I mean now with kids that
gets weird and I understand there's some
restrictions as far par in the
particulars of it I don't really know
where that line starts and stops so I'm
not going to lie to you on that the
underage aspect of things like recording
in schools I don't really know where
that line is so I'm not going to my main
concern on this is the federal
courthouse so just to let you know where
I'm going with this this is not to you
know creep at preschools I mean it has
no interest in that so so just for
clarification you're if I may I I
believe that there's already a statute
that covers that separately you I just
want to clarify that your your intention
of this is Court my intention to this is
reasserting State sovereignty yes for
courts thank
you I represent
Muse as I read your your bill it looks
like this would actually allow uh people
to Trail other people into bathrooms in
public buildings is is that is that true
I mean what would stop somebody from
doing that to me right now if I go to
the bathroom thank you break the
Privacy yeah I think it comes down to
questions of expectation of privacy that
would be I mean I just want to make this
clear I'm not a lawyer never claimed to
me I just yeah got it all right um
seeing no further questions thank you oh
sorry who had one up rent
Balden thank you for taking my question
are you aware of um or is you take into
consideration the um New Hampshire Court
rules that require courts to record all
proceedings um in audio format and
maintain those files should uh
participant in a proceeding request uh
copy I was not aware of that but I don't
believe I have to look into that before
I say that's true because I State yeah
state courts okay again this is more
aimed at the federal aspect but
I yes I public transparency in the
courts should be just a sacran principle
that we there should be no argument over
it's just
yeah representative
scitech you said in your testimony that
the federal government has not yet given
some of these plans to the Secretary of
State none of
them what do you have any realistic
expectation that this would actually be
done or observed by the federal
government you're referencing RSA 1231
I'm referencing your
remarks you you had I'm talking about
any anything you triy to do to restrict
or modify the behavior of the federal
government if you based on what you said
if there's a sign in a federal building
that says no
videotaping and you you're going to
claim concurrent jurisdiction I just
don't see it happening
it already did happen on September 11th
I did it I think what he's asking you is
do you have an expectation that if we
pass this law and the government signed
it that the federal government would pay
any attention to it whatsoever yes it's
Civil Disobedience you keep on getting
arrested until they just have to deal
with it I certain things come down to
will and I don't believe that the
federal government has that kind of will
to violate a state sovereignty that
explicitly especially yeah that's my I'm
willing to take this to the to the end
zone yeah thank you um representative n
thank you and thank you for taking my
question um the situation that you're
describing would be if someone wanted to
for their own protection record um a
situation where um you know their their
case their court case but is there
anything limiting this um uh someone
using that against someone who did not
want their case like they don't
according to this it doesn't seem they
necessarily uh need to be the person who
is on trial so this would this could be
used
in my opinion it could be used in a
malicious way to record someone else's
trial who wouldn't want that to be the
case am I right well yeah we could have
used this to record J Lane Maxwell's
trial public trial I think the public
needs to know what's going on federal
dollars are being spent for a purpose
your tax dollars I think you should know
what who and why they're Prosecuting
people do you know does that make any
sense yeah I just yeah um sorry follow
um yes I I see what you're saying I just
um what I'm what I'm thinking about is
situations where where it's a vulnerable
individual or uh someone who who could
be harassed in that way so that's that's
what I'm envisioning as a a kind of sad
by for clarification the court has the
ability to close certain hearings to the
public which would theoretically bar uh
someone from videotaping in that hearing
for example children or things of that
nature juveniles thank you okay thank um
see go
ahead thanks for taking another question
I think that raises a good point how do
you believe your legislation here would
affect family courts that for example
are permitted to
um uh bar people attending the hearing
from even speaking publicly about the
contents of the hearing um and I think
it's like a misdemeanor if like
you attend um a family court hearing
that's under such such a condition and
and if you um reveal any aspect of that
communication or what happened like how
would this interact with that
representative you asking about like a
gag order it's it's not a gag order it's
it's I think it's like an automatic
thing where if it's a particular type of
hearing no one who's attended or
participated in it can even speak to you
can't even tell like your mom how it
went okay or it's a misdemeanor how
would this interact with that
first off if I if the state is bringing
charges against you the idea that you
can't speak about that situation that's
that patriot act kind of nonsense that
we kind of accepted which is absurd but
getting back to what you're saying they
I think it's important
to there's different types of
Courts so the the true courts they're
under the Judiciary they're not these
hopefully uh F the testimony will
explain this better but some of these
courts are created by the legislature
and they're not necessarily true courts
in a sense of let's say like a
constitutional article 3 Court a federal
court they're operating under procedures
that don't fully align with the
Constitution because they're they're
enforcing um regulations versus actual
statute if that makes sense maybe I'm
misspeaking and I'll have to clarify
hopefully we have somebody coming up
again who kind of clarifies more so but
again I'll just say if we wanted to
alter this just to eliminate any of
those kind of issues if you wanted to
just modify this just to Federal Court
I'd be more than happy and I think it
gets the point of what's we're trying to
get across but one last thing on that
point again if if the state is bringing
charges against somebody I think it's
important for the taxpayers to realize
what's being done I mean as we heard on
the floor the other day um a certain
representative was being dragged through
the the department um dcyf Courts for
giving his child medication I mean that
you know yeah I think we need to kind of
figure out what the bureaucrats are
doing on our behalf which apparently is
not on our behalf
so thank you um no further questions
thank
[Music]
you um chair calls uh Nat Nat
Grace oh I know
him thank you Mr chair uh n Grace for
the municipal Association we do oppose
this bill based on the testimony the
sponsor it sounds like his intent is
really to uh narrow this to federal
courts we would have no opinion on that
but as written um the language is very
broad um it would allow recording in any
publicly accessible area of any public
building where in the state of New
Hampshire maintains either exclusive or
concurrent
jurisdiction um I understand he
referenced a specific State Statute
obviously we uh municipalities are
subdivisions of the state presumably
there's some sort of jurisdiction over
our property along with the state um so
our concern here is really this language
is is very broad um anything that's
publicly accessible in any public
building um and this modifies not only
the wiretapping statute but also the
right to no law um and you know
municipalities are perfectly fine with
things like the the um first Audits and
all those recordings that happen um
those happen quite frequently at many of
your municipalities um but we are
concerned about what any publicly
accessible area means so for example
we're and I'm sorry but representative
Muse you sort of stole my thunder here
um we are in the L right now this is
clearly a publicly accessible building
clearly the state has jurisdiction over
it it's um you know the bathroom is a
publicly accessible area
we don't want situations where people
recording in the bathroom because that's
going to result in further crimes
occurring and we would like to
discourage those from occurring um so if
this bill could be refined in such a way
that it really targets what the sponsor
wants uh that would be our
preference I'm happy to take any
questions the committee has thank you
with regard to your concerns about
restrooms and things of that nature
hasn't the court already kind of defined
where someone has reasonable expectation
of
privacy well that's under the context of
the currently existing statutory
language this would add new language in
there I don't I don't wear a black robe
so I couldn't tell you how the court May
interpret that um all right thank you so
to be clear the association if the bill
were uh limited and targeted at the
federal you have no opinion on the bill
I have no opinion on that thank
you representative scitec can you give
me part from Laboratory can you give me
an example of a publicly accessible
place that we could that a person could
not tape could not video
record you said it's overly broad I'd
like to an example of where you right
so
um there are yeah locker rooms are are a
good example I heard someone shout out
you know things where you might expect
people to have some sort of privacy
um even though it's publicly accessible
that's really what we're concerned about
we're not concerned about you know the
lobby of the town hall because we all
know you can record there if you
want and so if if I wanted to for
example go to a town hall and or or the
health department and I wanted to walk
through the halls and just videotape
that you're okay with that as long as
it's publicly accessible I mean if you
go to a town hall typically there's a
public area and a non-public area so you
know for example the town clerks in some
Town Halls are a little walled off
because that's where their offices they
have you know their accounting and
everything else you can't all allow the
public back there because people are
trying to work trying to do their thing
um but if somebody wants to stand in
front of the town clerk's window and
video cord record all day they're
allowed to do that we've seen that in
municipalities across the state okay
thank you um a couple of uh fan of some
of those interesting First Amendment on
video so I always makes a good debate um
representative rhods thank you Mr
chairman if you have if you have say an
employee of a of a public building and
they were having what they thought was a
private conversation say with human
resources is that considered would that
still be considered to be private or is
that not private because it's a public
building so again I think there's a
distinction between what's a publicly
accessible space and what's not not
typically human resource offices are
behind lock and key because they have
employee files and there's an intense
level of privacy associate with those
they have things like Social Security
numbers that we don't want to be
circulated out into the public because
that will result in identity theft um so
I would expect that in your scenario
that would be a private conversation
that would be occurring outside of the
the publicly accessible area okay good
thank
you
so I had a just a couple of uh questions
and wanted to get your opinion on a
couple of areas um associated with
public buildings that may or may not
fall under this one would be students
recording teachers in classrooms and the
other one would be uh at polling places
which usually are in public buildings uh
like schools and town halls um would
there be any restrictions at all where
people could go if uh this law was in
place so I don't represent schools so
I'm not sure what the the law is now
regarding regarding that uh recording of
students and teachers um so I'd prefer
not to comment on that and for the
second part I'd like to defer to the
Secretary of State's office because I
know there were several lawsuits about
recording and photographs and polling
places I honestly don't remember how
those came out um but I'm sure the
secretary does so I I defer to his
office that one and and just for the
answer to saving time um the sponsor has
been pretty clear that he If This Were
to pass through our committee he would
he would hope to see that it was just
limited to federal courts to avoid this
exact um Quagmire we're starting to go
down um any further
questions representative
Newman yeah your Association represents
municipalities and so it's not I mean
this deals with state and f State
concurrent do municipalities have any
concurrent buildings like that or do you
have examples of just what concurrent
means concurrent so that's one of my
questions um because municipalities are
subdivisions of the state so for example
when I used to work up in Littleton
State Police would often use our Police
Department to process people they've
arrested
um it made sense for them to do that
because it was quite a far trip back to
troop F
um so it was faster and more convenient
for everyone um and they were more
likely to get a bail commissioner
because we were closer to more people um
but so I'm not exactly sure what that
means and that's why we were concerned
with the language as
written thank you I I believe just for
clarification again the he was reading
from the statute that defines uh
concurrent ownership between and control
between the federal government and the
state government not between the state
entity is itself um so I think that's
what it meant yeah absolutely good just
about your clarification yeah so you
have a building where the federal
government owns or the state owns it but
the federal government does some things
in there or the federal has if it's
exclusive it's all federal activity in
that building and if it's concurrent
there could be activity on both parties
Parts not necessarily I believe what the
statute says is that land in the state
of New Hampshire that is seated to the
federal government to use for example
for a military base or a federal
courthouse Etc the state of New
Hampshire retains concurrent
jurisdiction over the land so the
question would be then who's controlling
it at the moment and can we both control
it and that that's the question of the
being raised thank you yeah um see you
no further questions thank you for your
testimony thank you Mr
chair the calls Mr
Staples
thank you so much uh so a lot of the
concerns that have been brought up by
the previous gentleman and some of these
reps here um are misplaced you we can
already film anything we can see in
public okay you can go to Glick verse
Kuni it's a 2011 First Circuit case and
it it was about the public recording
police officers in the course of their
duties but the ruling also applies to
all public officials so filming the
Department of Homeland Security when we
got arrested at the federal courthouse
the interesting thing is we're hearing
about First Amendment Auditors and all
that I am not a First Amendment auditor
a lot of people think I am because I I
record what I do whenever I'm dealing
with the
state um
but the post office has a poster that
says you're allowed to film the lobby
and that's what causes the controversy
in a lot of these first amendment audits
interestingly enough there is a poster
just like that at the federal courthouse
as representative Gerhard said there's a
plaque that says this building is
dedicated to the citizens of New
Hampshire as a public
forum so right on the plaque but then
the poster says we're allowed to film in
the lobby says we're allowed to film in
the
lobby so why were we arrest ticketed and
arrested by Homeland Security not for
filming in the lobby for disobeying an
order we got arrested in charge for
disobeying an order it's a catchall that
they use to keep us from nullifying
unconstitutional acts like this so we're
already allowed to film our public
officials in the course of their duties
so why can't we film people at the
courthouse in the course of their duties
and if the courts are already filming
everything and we can get access to it
but we have to pay for it why can't I
create my own
records that way I don't have to pay for
it and I can catch things and I have
caught things I was actually uh asked to
come down in film in Boston Court and I
did that and I I talked to the J I told
the judge and the judge allowed it
because they actually have a process for
asking permission which is what they
they try to do here in New Hampshire we
have a similar process process where
they want you to ask permission first
they tell you you're not allowed to but
if you press the issue then they say oh
well there's a form to fill out if you
do want to fil oh there's a form to fill
out why didn't you tell me that to begin
with why do I need to ask permission to
exercise a constitutional right I
don't right and that's why if you go to
my Supreme Court audits here in New
Hampshire where this rule 19 says you
shall be allowed to film in the the
courts and you can be limited by the
judge in a certain case if it's a
juvenile case or something like that and
that is also a kind of a problem like
with this family court the Jr hole thing
and all that he was not allowed to film
that so who knows what happened there
and why can't he film that and why can't
a student start filming something that's
going on and be a whistleblower in their
school whistleblowers don't always have
to be somebody that works for the state
right so why can't the kids film what's
going on in their classrooms and then
bring it to their parents film a teacher
or something like that and why can't a
parent film their interactions with the
school or a doctor their doctor things
like that so the ability to create our
own records and be secure in those
things is an inherent right anywhere we
can travel and go in public I can have a
body cam on just like a police off why
can only the police and the state create
these records and then we can't even get
the body cam footage what's the point of
body cam footage when you can't get it
unless there is a physical assault a
physical
injury doesn't make any sense so rule 19
already allows recording in
courts and the
stenographers there's there is a audio
recording but the stenographers are
actually typing what they hear so there
is a human error aspect there as well
and I've seen that in cases that I've
had where I get the transcript that you
have to pay thousands of dollars for and
then it's been transcribed incorrectly
by the
stenographer okay and then if I have my
own video I can refute that correct if I
don't I can't so why can't we create our
own
records um and like I said they make us
pay for those too and it's a revenue
generating
scheme polling places we're already
allowed to record in polling places you
can't go inside the the where there's a
reasonable expectation of privacy
bathrooms locker rooms things like that
I mean come on let's get real people
that's that's not allowed that's not
what people are trying to
do
so I was actually recording at a YDC
hearing and when I left the prosecutor
when the judge came during a break the
the the prosecutor came back and said
there is
an
unrepresented plaintiff victim from the
YDC case here filming we don't want him
or anyone else to be able to film any of
these hearings in the
future why why is
that where is the transparency here why
can't we record our courts and our
public officials we can I do it and they
don't arrest me because they know I'm
willing to get arrested but most people
do not have the gumption and knowledge
that I do to nullify these things and
have the courage to get arrested at the
drop of a hat
so I'd like to also say that when these
things do happen I mean I had a 5day
13-hour trial for disorderly conduct of
saying yeah
allegedly I mean
where is is is is the money going for
for these type of
things
um so also with the public places if
it's a public place they have the
restricted areas they have to be there's
a notice there's always a sign when
there's a restricted area so if there's
a restricted area you cannot film there
it's not a public place okay so just you
can't turn public places into private
places just cuz you don't want people
recording
there can't say oh well it's a it's a
limited public forum it doesn't say
limited public forum on the plaque does
it no it doesn't so this does not just
apply to the federal courthouse this
100% applies to anywhere in
public um and the penalty there should
be a penalty they shouldn't be hitting
the Panic alarm and arresting people
it's embarrassing when you watch the
video of me dealing with these public
officials who literally have no clue
what they're talking about it is
absolutely embarrassing and then when
they continue to try to perpetuate this
unconstitutional illegal practice this
will will nip it in the bud because
they're going to have a penalty attached
so why is it whenever there's a law to
prohibit the state actors from doing
anything there's no penalty
attached like with the body cam footage
law
okay so that is is odd and strange to me
um
and yeah I think that just about covers
it thank you if you have any questions
any
questions I I have a quick one um so the
arrest you were arrested for videotaping
in the courtroom charged with uh disobey
dising the order to fail to comply with
ful order which was not a lawful order
right and I anticipate you correct me if
I'm wrong they're actually probably
going to use the videotape of you there
that they took as evidence against you
they did not take any evidence they
don't even know if I was recording he
asked me did they have security cameras
is my do but they don't have my device
they don't even know if my device was
actually recording they do cuz I shared
the video but you know what I mean they
don't they would not know that they
didn't confiscate and I'm not charged
with recording because it says right
there I'm allowed to film in the lobby
yeah and if you watch the video I didn't
disobey anything he said are you
recording are you recording and I just I
went silent I didn't say anything and
then he just ends up arresting me so why
are you arresting us for filming which
is supposedly you know you're saying
it's against and then you're charging us
with something else gotcha okay thank
you uh representative
Balden thanks for taking my question
I've been I've Had The Misfortune I
guess of being present in the past for
uh hearing on a protective order and um
it was uncomfortable for me just sitting
in the pews listening to this person
discuss um a sex assault that they
alleged experienced and um you know
going into detail especially with the
judge asking questions to try to I think
assess the veracity of the claims you
know so there was a an uncomfortable
amount of detail and I can't imagine
what it might be like to be the person
talking about that stuff or the person
accused of it especially if I was
wrongly
accused um do you have any commentary on
how someone might feel if they were in
on either side of that situation either
wrongly accused or having genuinely
suffered a really painful experience and
the possibility that maybe even a
stranger could record and publish that
conversation in a courtroom as as
opposed
to maybe just having the comfort of
knowing that the conversation kind of
stays in the
courtroom well you bring up a good point
it has to do with feelings and
emotions and none of this has anything
to do with anything when it comes to
rights your feelings and your emotions
about a certain thing are irrelevant and
I'm not trying to be mean here but what
is the difference between it being very
difficult for someone to get up and
testify and it's being recorded by the
state and it's being witnessed by all
kinds of people and there's multiple
cameras in in in audio devices so what's
the difference if there's another one or
another one or another one there is no
difference the difference is that the
public gets access to what is happening
in our system it provides transparency
it allows people to say oh look at this
person making these false claims their
story is inconsistent it doesn't even
make sense and then the public can make
up their own mind as well why are we you
know trying to hide the truth and what
is really going on in society and try to
make it like the state is the Arbiter of
everything that happens with no you work
for us you work for us and we have the
right to film what is happening whether
it's someone who's it's not about the
person who's getting the false
accusation and all that it's about
filming the judges in the process and
it's already being recorded So what is
the difference of some media
organization or me it's because you
don't like me certain people don't like
me and you don't want me to have that
information that's
it no thank you that thanks thank
you
thanks uh the chair calls Kate Horan
organ
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Kate Horan I
represent the New Hampshire Association
of counties which is all the elected and
appointed officials uh in your County
government uh the association is also
opposed to this bill for many similar
reasons as the municipal Association and
would agree If This Were amended to be
restricted to just federal courts we
would have no position on the bill um I
was asked to bring up two potential
situations that have not been mentioned
yet uh one is you all know there are 11
County nursing homes each county has one
Coos has two those are publicly
accessible buildings and those are
people's homes th if this were allowed
to go through someone could be recording
someone who may not want to be recorded
in their own home uh the second
situation would be our County
correctional facilities they set up
rules and procedures around filming um
to protect not only their residents but
their staffs and we need to be able to
maintain that control um I am happy to
answer any questions that the committee
has and I'll conclude my
testimony just um one more the same
thing I asked previously clarification
if we limited it to Federal buildings we
have no position then thank you any
questions on the
counties representative Newman
yeah I I just didn't hear what the what
you said the second thing was could you
just repeat that uh the around the
correctional facilities thank
you representa
s that's all thanks thank
you Kang L Li Kang I I got it backwards
I
think hello ladies and gentlemen um I
like to just maybe step back a little
bit um from all the arguing that we've
had in the last couple of minutes and
think about where our powers are derived
from and the r and the and the the um
delegation of powers that is given to us
by the Constitution so uh for example
I'm going to make a an anal analogy here
the police force in Massachusetts can
can carry firearms that contain more
than 10 rounds in their magazines but
they say the people of Massachusetts
cannot now that that's a paradox and it
doesn't make sense because the police
officers work for the people so if the
people can't carry um 10 Rounds then
neither should the police officer and
similarly if the police officer can
carry 15 rounds or more then that's the
power derived from the people and in the
sense of uh recording and whether or not
that may infringe upon rights and
privacies of of certain persons either
at institutions um nursing homes or in
certain courts and so forth the real
question is does the
state have the power to record that that
um
scene that Forum or that place or that
uh that public area and if the state has
the power to
record that
Forum then gushed on it so do the people
because we gave the state that power to
begin with the state cannot just record
something and keep it from the public
and expect that no one else can
challenge that wherever the state can
keep a record I suggest that we the
people can keep the same record that's
only fair not only is it only fair it's
where where where the state gets their
power
from um also uh I think there was a
question that I I was asked to addressed
by uh representative geart regard
regarding the court system um and he
wanted to explain the difference between
administrative courts and uh chapter 3
or article 3 courts um the distinction
between an a legislative court or an
Executive Court and a Judicial Court is
that the former to regards uh rights
that extend or arise from a from from
the
government for example a licensing uh
Forum a forum that talks about a medical
license that is a privilege extended to
the individual through the government
therefore the government has the power
to establish its own form for its
adjudication a a tax court for example
is a legislative court that is a forum
where it is presumed that the taxpayer
received remunerations from the
government that is now putting them into
this form that they call the tax Court
the only court that is actually a
Judicial Court uh is uh is is a court
that adjudicates private Rights Article
3 courts are different uh because they
adjudicate the private right
that are recognized um by the
Constitution that that's a case in
Northern pipeline versus Marathon
pipeline the Supreme Court decision in
1982 was there anything else you wanted
me to address
okay uh did you have any questions uh
sir or
ma'am thank
you um any further Witnesses for this
bill there being none I hereby close the
public hearing on H B
13 oh excuse me
1455 and open the public hearing on HP
15 excuse me that was 1455 I opened the
public he on HP
1535 good morning Jason Gard Franklin
Northfield I represent marac
25 this bill prohibits mandatory
participation in digital identification
systems the short
explanation is I'm worried about an
increasing social credit type dystopia
developing and this is to kind of nip
that all in the bud to prevent national
ID or whatever you want to call it from
being formed which is when I was growing
up was always explained as the way that
Nazi Germany took over the world
essentially so that's to be thing to be
the Beed at any attempt to Institute it
what I want to bring your attention to
which unfortunately is not in this copy
I
have are the
penalties line
18 so F require course or compel
includes physical violence threat
intimidation retaliation the
conditioning of any private or public
benefit or Care on consent to
participation including employment
promotion or other employment benefit or
by any means that causes a reasonable
person of ordinary susceptibilities to
acques to participation when he or she
otherwise would
not what I'm concerned about is people
that receive public benefits the most
vulnerable in society being forced into
this system do you want your your EBT
card or whatever whatever the state
level stuff is and then being forced to
go undergo all these kind of digitized
identification Biometrics all that kind
of nonsense I'm just I don't want to see
that happen and I'm worried that the
people at the bottom rungs of society
will acques much faster than others who
are self-sufficient and don't need that
immediate government assistance to get
by through the
week I think the bill is pretty
self-explanatory if there's any
questions I'd be glad to address them
yes um so under digital identification
uh line eight um means a set of
digitally captured attributes such as
name date of birth G gender um other
personal information combined with
credentials that are linked to a unique
identifier does that not the description
or ID of a driver's
license or a birth
certificate well birth certificate would
be digitized they are now I think that
they scan them all in they're all what
oh no all
right so I we're getting there faster
than I thought um you're about 10 years
late yeah all right well we're going to
have to fix that um is your intent more
of a some type of a um
video or fingerprint or I'm I'm really
worried about just connecting the
Biometrics so Biometrics and well just
connecting all of it together to create
this national ID that they'll eventually
push to get on airplanes and all the
rest kind of trying to nip all that in
the butt to remove New Hampshire from
that whole Matrix so the it falls apart
so some type of Citizen profile that the
government would keep on we all know
it's going to the credit uh social
credit score thing everybody kind of
knows that by now all right so taking it
the bill in that from that
Viewpoint um okay instead of focusing on
on the language of eight looking at it
from what it would do if we could craft
it that way I got it okay further
questions see none thank you for your
testimony or did someone have one no
okay thanks thank you um next um chair
calls Frank
Staples
yeah I know I know movie star um so just
real real quick couple things um and I
don't know if this is in there exactly
but we're already doing a lot of
tracking and tracing of people um you
know sometimes I smoke cigarettes
sometimes I drink alcohol and I've gone
to 7-Eleven I don't have my ID and they
want to scan this thing so that they now
know that I just bought cigarettes and
somebody knows where I am and you know
maybe Bad actors come maybe somebody
hacked the system and now they know
where you are and they know what you're
buying and they know your patterns and
your routines and they have algorithms
to to to track and Trace all those type
of things and come up with profiles and
are we secure in our persons in our in
our or are we not right so I would also
suggest putting something in here to
stop that practice of scanning people's
IDs um you know that is they're getting
certain corporations to create a policy
when there I don't believe there is a
state law for that cuz other places
don't do it they claim it's a state law
but it's not and this is you know a way
to do the whole social credit score and
say oh do you have your vax pass you
can't come in without it and this will
be the easy way to to uh to Ram that
thing through and then where does it
stop with the vax pass did you get your
flu pass did you did you get you know
all these other whatever else they
decide to come up with and yeah we need
to nip this in the butt and shut this
down they've been trying to do the real
ID thing for a while and are we a
sovereign state as our constitution says
or not that is the
question
questions seeing none thank you thank
you any further Witnesses who wish to
testify on this bill there being none I
am going to close public hearing on HP
1535 and we have a 10-minute
recess
okay
145 okay we're going to open the public
hearing on HB 169 and I invite sponsor
to come introduce this
bill
thank you chairman members of the
committee last one for the day I
appreciate your
patience Jason Gard rep uh Franklin
Northfield marac
25 so this bill comes from a personal
situation having a federal felony I was
looking to have my rights restored by
the
governor because in 607a it allows
for the restoration of your rights well
it specifically says that the governor
shall issue a
certificate restoring them and I
actually this was a few days ago I
received this the actual certificate
from the governor so it does actually
occur which is nice to know did take a
little bit of effort but the reason this
law I believe is necessary is
because there are certain
aspects that are bit unclear
specifically it says in part well the
Old Law it says in part that your course
of Liberties shall be restored and
you'll suffer no Corruption of
blood but it doesn't uh specifically say
the right to bear arms so this is I look
at this more as a clarification overall
for the bill although there are certain
things that are added for people who
have finished their
sentences
and further testimony will clarify some
other points
but we look on page two line 10 be able
to serve on a
jury and we have the right to vote which
surprisingly is allowed in Vermont and
Maine for State prisoners while they're
serving their sentences they are allowed
to
vote now addressing that in the fiscal
note I don't know how they came with
these numbers
but we have the Department of
Corrections indicates that in order to
comply with this bill four additional
administrator one positions would be
required three positions would be in
conquer and one would be in Berlin these
position the positions would act as
Liaisons between cities and towns and
docc residents in order to register
residents to vote obtain absentee
ballots and facilitate all other
elements outlined in the Secretary of
State's manual for elections okay so
they would also provide voting process
education to all
residents and issue them well they don't
know if the doc issued IDs would be
satisfactory which I don't see why they
wouldn't but e either way they they
claim that to do so would cost
$444,000 the first year and then it goes
to
$456,000 in 2027 unfortunately I left my
paper where I did the math complicated
math over there but it comes out to be
there's around 3,000 inmates in New
Hampshire
it comes at to
$197 per inmate per year in order to
have to facilitate their ability to vote
so I'm going to write to them and offer
to do it for $2 an inmate and make a
bunch of money and just send them a
letter because I don't understand why
this would be that complicated I
actually registered to vote while I was
in straford County Jail pre-trial back
in 2008 I voted for Ron Paul in the
primary but the the point being is that
it's not complicated staff can easily
take a picture send it to local in
authorities and be done with it it's
this so I don't know if this was
designed to try to you know destroy that
idea but anyway in the New Hampshire
state constitution it allows all people
to vote so it's simply following in line
with the Constitution and also our
sister states of Vermont and
Maine
additionally this if we look at page two
at the bottom line
33 this statute shall be construed to be
in accordance with 18 USC section 922 G1
this is the federal felon in possession
act or law and
I'll
reference crm1 1499 I can send the link
in the testimony to the um committee but
this States this is from the Department
of Justice a frequently litigated issue
under 922 G1 is whether a convicted
felon is exempt from the prohibitions of
the statute because of a postconviction
restoration of civil rights under state
law in accordance with 18 USC 921 a20 a
conviction does not disqualify an
individual from possessing firearms if
the person convicted has had civil
rights
restored and it goes on and further
testimony can can go more detailed into
this but what I'm worried about from a
personal point of view is with my newly
minted certificate from the governor
that there'll be some gray area as far
as restoration of Rights and what that
deline because this the feds already
seem to acknowledge it but it would be
helpful for the state law to leave no
stone unturned because it already says
that all of your rights are restored so
that's the essence of this as far as I'm
concerned because it it goes on
additionally to say that on page two
line 16 right retained by former felons
except as otherwise provided by this
chapter or by the Constitution of the
state a person pre previous previously
convicted of a felony shall not suffer
civil death or Corruption of blood or
sustain loss of civil rights of forture
state of property but retains all of his
or her rights political personal civil
and otherwise including the right to
hold public office or employment to vote
serve on any jury the right to keep in
be arms in defense of that person the
person's family the person's property
and the state to hold receive transfer
property enter into contract Sue and be
sued and to hold offices of private
trust in accordance with the law so
that's where I was going with this
hopefully I kind of got close to it and
I'll take any questions that people may
have thank you um if you could just for
clarification it was it was my
understanding that if you were convicted
of a federal crime only the federal
government could restore those rights is
that incorrect the state can do it well
it's the feds defer to the states that's
what this the release from them was
saying under 922 G1 which is the Felon
possession so the Felon possession law
the feder the Federal level is funky
anyway because it has a 0o to 10
guideline so it's kind of just how the
judge is feeling that day and to me it
seems absurd that you're exercising a
constitutional right and now you're just
rolling the dice and up to a decade I
mean we're not dinosaurs a decade's a
long time so I think that this okay
getting back to your question because I
totally went off course this um the
federal position is that it's up to the
states to decide if your right to
restore and if your right to restore
then the feds will respect that decision
okay unless I'm totally missing
something and I'm willing for
clarification but that seems it was just
my understanding that the states could
restore your rights for State crimes the
federal government had to restore your
rights and it was a process to do that
through the FBI or the Department of
Justice but I I could be incorrect um I
will look into it thank you uh further
questions okay representative Stone
thank you thank you for taking my
question so the the document you're in
possession of now from the governor's
office was that in regards to State
charges or federal
charges I don't have any state charges
oh I mean the pending federal court
thing the for recording in the public
court I'm well I'm just curious a
followup I'm just curious uh how the
governor of any state has the authority
to nullify anything from the federal
level well the yes so it's actually the
governor is simply restoring your rights
under the state at the state level so I
don't have the previous oh here it is
it's actually on the Forum so I'll read
it to in accordance with the provisions
of RSA 607 A5 this certificate of
discharge being issued to the individual
named below in order to memorialize the
fact that this individual's rights to
vote and hold and to hold any future
public office are hereby restored an
individual suffers no other disability
by virtue of his conviction and sentence
as otherwise provided by RSA 607a by the
New Hampshire Constitution or by any
other doly enacted law of the State of
New
Hampshire then
which this um is not in the law they
seem to add a little caveat this
certificate of discharge is not affect
any rights impacted impacted by the
indiv individual's conviction so I'm
going to bring this up with the governor
because he just simply added this in I
it's a protection thing on his part but
that has no basis in the law so but to
answer your question
that's the go it's I wish I had the
actual law firing but it states that if
a if it's state level offense you go to
the court of conviction to receive your
discharge but if it's Federal you go to
the governor and he shall issue this
certificate to restore your rights did I
make answer that Conor thank you okay
representative s thank you and thank you
for taking my question um I I don't have
an objection to um people who are in
prison having their rights to vote
restored um what I'm curious about is if
hypothetically we had you know Jim Bob
from um Maine who was convicted of
murder in New Hampshire and is therefore
in New Hampshire jail prison system as a
result yeah um
where um so they're a resident of main
prior to their
conviction um
what what's the jurisdiction for where
they are entitled to vote gotcha so
that's page three line
21 a person incarcerated in in the state
may claim domicile for voting purposes
in the municipality where that person
has last previously established a fixed
and principal residence to which the
person intends to return and that's also
how Maine and Vermont do it because you
don't want
just you don't want one let's say
conquered as a prison so there's a whole
bunch of people there you don't want
them now just having that extra block of
voting power it just throws the whole
system off and I'm not in favor of that
unless you guys want you know felon Jim
Bob being in the mayor or something
but
followup okay so if if Jim Bob from
Maine has would then not be eligible for
this because Jim Bob would if his last
place of well you said both domicile and
residency which are two different terms
based on New Hampshire election law but
um
would we is he eligible to vote I'm
still not clear based on your reading of
the of the rules on here okay I'm a
little confused about the Dom I have to
look into that I but it just says that
the last previously established fixed
and principal residence so I mean if I
don't think I think his last fixed in
principal residence would be Maine and
Maine allows State prisoners to vote so
all the more power to him he can vote in
Maine
pretty much where you lived when you
were arrested is where you could vote um
based on that the proposed language
yeah yeah representative
Muse C can you just clarify um which
specific rights the governor has
restored to you and which for which
offenses which specific
offenses the it would be my federal
felonies so I I can list them if you
want real quick we have conspiracy to
commit offenses against the United
States conspiracy that was the first one
right and then we have conspiracy to um
conspiracy commit offenses conspiracy
to impede offic of the United States
from discharging their duties repres
gead are they listed on the document
this no okay then you don't need to tell
us all your well no I have no problem
with it it's it's all political crimes
but the the right that are being
restored to you are all your core civil
rights and you suffer no Corruption of
blood which Somebody explain to me I
didn't know what Corruption of blood me
apparently it's your heirs so you don't
have any issue with somebody's you know
saying okay you can't um provide you
know give this estate to your son or
whatever
so or your your heirs be punished based
on something you did yeah that's yeah
sins of the father okay um further
questions representative
Murray um thank you chairman and thank
you for taking my question I was just
curious at um on page two at the
beginning it says when you're serving
your sentence that you temporarily lose
your right to serve on a jury but then
underneath on line 16 when it says it's
talking about the rights
retained
um it says serve on a jury there as
well is that like I'm just confused by
that section are is it differentiating
in those two cases or it's just about
what goes back to the convicted person
after well so at at line one it's any
person serving a sentence for a felony
conviction from time of his or her
sentence until the final discharge from
such sentence shall temporarily lose his
or her right to then we have line 10 b
sering a jury but then underneath it
would be
16 the rights retained by the former
felon would be serve on a jury right to
keep and be arms and so forth so simply
when you're in jail you can't be on a
jury which I mean kind of agree with
that you
know I see no further questions thank
you thank
you okay um the chair calls Frank
Staples thank you so much uh as many of
you may remember actually
testified um on a other Bill about felon
gun rights and I discussed this RSA 607a
as it stands at length and I was
promised a response from the attorney
general it's about a year ago on my
analysis and Muse rep Muse here brings
up a good point um which specific rights
are you know
restored and if you go
to 607 A5
two with this certificate I have a
problem with the certificate that uh was
filed for Jason Gerard uh reip
Gerard says in accordance with the
provisions of 607 A5 paragraph 2 the
certificate of discharge is being issued
to the individual named below in order
to memorialize the fact that this
individual's rights to vote and hold any
future public office are hereby restored
and that's not actually what this law
says second
here so it says
60785 paragraph 2 if the sentence was
imposed in another state or in a federal
court and the convicted person has
similarly been discharged by the
appropriate authorities the governor of
this state upon application and proof of
the discharge in such form as the
governor may require shall issue a
certificate stating that the rights
enumerated in paragraph one um have been
restored to the defendant under the laws
of this state paragraph one
says if the sentence was imposed in this
state the order certificate or other
instrument of discharge given to a
person sentenced for a felony upon his
discharge after completion of his
sentence or after service under
probation or parole shall state that the
defendant's rights to vote and hold any
future public office of which he was
deprived by this chapter thereby
restored and that he suffers no other
disability by virtue of his conviction
and sentence except as otherwise
provided by this chapter the copy of the
order shall be filed with the clerk of
the court and um this caveat in here at
the end it says this certificate does
not affect any rights impacted by the
individual's conviction under Federal
federal law well we heard testimony
today on other bills saying well how are
we supposed to determine the state
determine federal law so why is the
state trying to determine federal law
when we can just go to the federal law
right here this
1435 CRM this is from the Federal
Government website 1435 post conviction
restoration of civil rights exactly what
we're talking about and this is what I
read the last time verbatim a frequently
ated issue under 9922 G1 which is the
federal firearms statute it contains an
exemption to who is considered a felon
and um the Felon is exempt from the
prohibitions of this federal statute
because of the post conviction
restoration of civil rights under state
law state law so how is it that this
thing says that this restoration of
rights does not affect your your federal
rights when this you know it it actually
does the feds don't have a process to
restore your rights you have to do it
through the state so they rely on the
state
restoration okay to determine whether or
not you're a felon and they they do that
by do you get your Three core civil
rights back the right to vote serve on a
jury and hold public office and if you
do get those rights back you're not
considered a felon for purposes of the
federal firearm statute so if the feds
are saying that you're not a felon based
on the state restoration
statute if we
read the 607a on its face
now it does give you back all your
rights but it does not specifically
mention the right to serve on a jury
which is why it's been added in there
and the right to keep and bear arms in
defense of that person their family
their property in the state and so some
of the changes here also have to do with
the lenser scheme that they're trying to
apply to all people that would be you
know the lenser scheme as it stands in
my opinion is constitutional it's being
applied unconstitutionally when it's
being applied to everyone Under the Sun
that you have to get a license to carry
a firearm which is an offensive right
it's an it's a privilege that you get
for being a security guard or police
officer or whatnot you now have the
right to actually use it for offensive
purposes and there's training involved
and and whatnot so the average person
shouldn't have and does not need a
license for any of of our rights right
we have the right to keep and bear arms
so there's a dis there's a distinction
between
um the bearing of arms and the license
requirement and part of the problem is
that a lot of these Second Amendment
lawyers are using this as a revenue
generating stream through the annulment
process and they're trying to make
everyone go through the inment process
to get a license to carry when they
don't need that license we get the right
automatically and here's the thing
whether the governor wrote this or not
does not affect the fact that Mr Gerhard
already automatically
gets his rights back via statute and
that's also if you read this
postconviction restoration from the feds
that's if it's gr if it's given back via
statute automatically you automatically
get it whether or not the clerk files
this document like they're supposed to
and we have a problem when people go to
the clerk of the court of conviction to
get their State uh certificate a
discharge there's this rrim role that
they send the person to offender records
you got to go to offender records then
offender record says no you got to talk
to the clerk the clerk says you so
they're not actually it says the clerk
shall file this and the clerks are not
filing it but we did uh clarify that as
well to make it so that it's not a
problem and it recognizes that if the
clerk doesn't file it once someone asks
for it to be filed it needs to be filed
we need to be able to get access to not
have to file a Rand damis with the
Supreme Court to get the clerk to do
their job or to get the offender record
to do their job which I done that for
Valley Street for this exact thing to
get the certificate discharge filed
right um
[Music]
so like I said there is this federal
exemption that relies on the state and
this cannot be reconciled without this
bill passing and being clarified of of
which rights like M says where isn't it
specified why isn't it specified that
all all of our state it could just say
all of our state constitutional rights
are hereby restored you don't even have
to put the Firearms thing in but if all
our rights are restored which is kind of
what it already says um then why
wouldn't it uh exclude Firearms unless
it's in there somewhere and it is not in
there
anywhere is it no so the license is an
offensive privilege not a right and
we're trying to distinguish between that
here um
and with as far as the voting in prison
thing and jail and whatnot um it's
similar to like having to file people
have to file their taxes right in jail
and prison there's no leaz on or
anything like that you got to do it
yourself okay so the onus is on the
inmate to register and do these things
and they can do that through their case
manager that is what the case managers
are for okay so it's it's not we don't
need positions to suck up $100,000 for
your friend here and your friend there
these four four positions for $100,000
each it's ridiculous um it's being done
to either pad somebody's Pockets or try
to find a reason to not allow that to
happen
um
so see
here and it's interesting at the end
here where they say uh the Department of
Justice states that it is clear that if
this uh if this bill would result in any
additional cost it is not clear if this
bill would result um in any additional
cost the most significant potential cost
could be litigation expenses were the
legality of this legislation to be
challenged relative to 18 uh USC 922
regarding the right to keep and be arms
well we just went over that 922 relies
Li on the state scheme with this uniform
act on status of convicted persons this
would just um clarify it and actually I
I would posit that this would prevent
litigation from happening because what's
to say that I as a former
felon I have the I have all my rights
even though I don't have my certificate
of discharge I'm not on probation I'm
not on parole or anything I can go get a
gun I can open carry I can bear arms
right and then I get arrested for a
felony and have to go through that whole
process and then that's some litigation
right there all right that's what we're
trying to avoid here um with this
bill and I'm curious as to why the
AG has neglected to respond on this
maybe we need the Supreme Court to come
down with an order and clarification on
on on what specific rights are restored
and retained by
people I would think it goes without
saying if you understand expressio unus
exclusio
alarus principle legal principle if you
don't know that you should because
basically all of New Hampshire law is
written with that in mind so you have to
read it in a certain way and divine what
the law actually
says
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank
you
next um Mr
Kangley hello ladies and gentlemen my
name is Kang Lou um I think one of the
major confusions that bring up a lot of
these issues is our use of words and
specifically the use of the word carry
and the word bear uh now people think
that the word carry means you just have
something in your hand or you're moving
it around in a car for example but
actually carrye is a very specific legal
term and if you would bear with me I'm
just going to read a couple of uh uh
United States Supreme Court decisions um
from Mulla versus Virginia Williams
versus United States South Carolina
versus un united states and United
States versus rabinovitz and it goes
something like this it's Elementary law
that every statute is to be read in the
light of the Constitution and every word
must have its due force and appropriate
meaning and no word is to be regarded as
unnecessary or needlessly added the
Constitution is a written instrument and
as such its meaning does not alter when
that that which it meant when adopted it
means now and words in the Constitution
must be read with a gloss of the
experience of those who have who framed
them and would receive the significance
of the experience to which they were
addressed a significance not to be found
in the dictionary the Constitution is
therefore not only the supreme law of
the land but it's also a dictionary and
the law is the definition and limitation
of power that's yiko versus the United
States now since the legislature cannot
invoke the sovereignty of the people to
override their will as declared in the
Constitution and the and the legislature
cannot redefine the words in the
Constitution from which it alone derives
its power to legislate the words to keep
and bear arms life liberty private
property house personal effects Etc
speak to those rights and properties
which are beyond the Constitutional
power of the legislature to
reach now let's take that in context
with the word carry
uh specifically we look at the early
founding documents like the United
States Constitution and even the
Massachusetts constitution in the United
States Constitution the word carry means
to carry into execution the foregoing
powers and in the Massachusetts
Constitution that's mentioned about five
or six times and it means to carry out
legal obligations to carry law into
effect to carry on the powers and duties
of public officers carry on the
Constitution and to carry out the will
of the people in other words the word
carry means a Duty or power of
government and that's true no no matter
if you look at the Constitution or if
you look at the statutes which are
written uh written for the word carry
for example um police officers have a
duty to carry firearms it's a duty in
power you can carry on a business uh you
can carry on the performance of their
duties with a firearm so what I'm
reaching here is that felon
whether they as soon as they've left
prison whe as soon as they've left their
confines of
incarceration they are by definition
restored of those rights which are given
to them by by God and protected by the
Constitution because even a felon who
was who may have done something wrong in
the past they don't deserve to be left
vulnerable um as as you as you may know
uh the Supreme Court in in deseni versus
WI says that the state has no
affirmative duty to protect uh citizens
but it cannot take away the ability of
that citizen to defend
himself and obviously um when you
deprive a man of his right to bear arms
you've done that and and I think the
bill in this case um wants to codify the
restoration of that right the right to
keep and bear arms and that's
distinguished from
the entitlement to carry a firearm in
the performance of duties or for hire
and and and I wanted to make that
distinction clear because it was alluded
to by the previous speaker as well does
anyone have any
questions ly uh representative Harry
gather thank you for taking my question
you um alluded to some cases from
different states do you have anything if
from New Hampshire uh the the cases
which I alluded to were Supreme Court
decisions okay and therefore they do
apply to New Hampshire thank
you see no further questions oh
representative
PR so if you're out on
parole does this kick in or do you have
to complete your whole sentence first
it's my understanding that if the if
you're on parole then in Ence
the state has protective Powers over you
because they have custody Powers over
you right because they have custody they
have to have the duty of protection and
therefore in theory you're being
protected by a state and therefore you
do not have the right to defend yourself
okay that's the that's the
Constitutional analysis that's what I
thought I just wanted to make sure
that representative
Balden I'm sorry um I raised my hand too
quickly but um I could have sworn that
somewhere in in existing law it
specifies that um if you're on
parole or
probation it is considered having served
your time does anyone else see that um
and I
just uh can you repeat
that oh on
page one
they yeah you're talking about the bill
though she's asking about existing
statute oh yeah
um so do you have any commentary I guess
on um 26 and 27 of the first page of the
legislation um where it states any
person who's on probation of parole
shall be considered to be fully
discharged that was already existing in
the law it already says that I mean in
in in in uh light of your most recent
comments thank
you it says any person who is on
probation or parole shall be considered
to be finally discharged for the
purposes of this chapter
um I I have no opinion on that because I
didn't I didn't write that I believe
it's already in the statute is that
correct if you're on probation or parole
you can limit you for possessing weapons
right yeah yeah it's under the federal
law it's not considered wrapped up until
you're wrapped up um okay thank you
thank you thank you sir
um the state uh excuse me the state the
chair calls uh Jeff White and
Jane
[Music]
fiream
good afternoon
Representatives uh thank you for
allowing me to speak my name is Jeff
White I am uh with the Department of
Corrections as the Director of the
division of field services overseeing
probation parole victim services and
collections uh I'm here to speak to you
today about the house bill 1619 FN
relative to status of convicted
persons
uh the Department of Corrections is
opposed the bill for several reasons but
most importantly it's due to the
increased safety risk risks it poses to
our probation parole officers the
legislation in question would allow for
individuals who are under supervision
through probation or parole to have the
right to carry a
firearm it's in the bill it's in the
bill line
2627 the Department's probation parole
officers routinely enter homes of
individuals on supervision which is
inherently risky undertaking anyways if
an individual under supervision is given
the right to carry firearms in already
risky situation could become exp
exponentially more
dangerous this scenario would be
untenable and will lead to more adverse
outcome for our officers up to an
including the risk of death it's
important to note that convicted felons
is determined by the judicial judicial
system to have previously violated
felony level laws and exhibit impaired
judgment additionally the department
will require additional funding for four
administrators for positions to be added
uh for us to comply with the bill three
of these positions would be located in
conquer one would be located in Berlin
these positions would act as Liaisons
between cities towns and Departments of
Corrections residents in order to
register residents to vote obtain
absentee ballots and to facilitate all
the other elements as outlined in the
New Hampshire Secretary of State's
Manual of procedures for State elections
these administrator one positions would
also provide voting process education to
all residents currently residents only
possess doc issued identification and it
is unclear if this identification would
be acceptable to register to vote the
department has many residents whose last
known address are out of state and
residents who are part of the interstate
compact program who would need to be
registered to vote in New
Hampshire I would like to thank the
committee for giving me the opportunity
to testify today and I'm happy to take
any
questions thank you um did you want to
add anything Mr gr okay thank you
representative
new
thank you Mr chair and um thank you for
taking my question um not to to give any
opinion on the overall bill but
um it just concerns me a little bit uh
people being out on probation or parole
um that they would still be considered
dangerous and I was wondering if you
could speak a little bit more to that
because I would think that they wouldn't
be released if they were they are
inherently dangerous we are trying to
rehabilitate part of supervision being
on probation or parole is to continue
that Rehabilitation process to
reintegrate them and to ensure they're
in complying with the conditions of
release uh the argument that was given
about a discharge of sentence and that
would include probation and parole being
discharged upon release from prison to
me is ludicrous the judge orders a
sentence of your senten to this much
time in prison followed by this much
time on probation or parole the judge
does not sentence to just prison and
forget about everything else afterwards
that is part of of the sentence it's not
discharged upon release from
facility thank you representative Stone
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question generally when
someone's on probation parole do they
have either a suspended or additional
time hanging over their head if they
violate the conditions of their
probation of parole yes thank you on
parole they definitely do because
they're released before the maximum term
of their sentence on a regular basis and
they can be sent back in front of the
parole board follow up please follow so
that would be the utilized term in the
industry as a condition of release that
is correct thank
you
saley thank you Mr chair Mas ask two
questions yeah thank you um my first
question and thank you for taking my
question is um do you know the rate of
rism yes thank you for saying that word
for me um particularly for people who
have um committed VI what we what what
most people would consider violent
crimes or even just generally the rate
of the rate of recidivism overall from
the last um numbers that we had was
around 43% but I can get you the exact
number for that thank you um I would
have to see if we would be able to break
it down by crime for you I don't have
that okay thank you and um my second
question and thank you for allowing that
Mr chair is
um if all of the terms other than the
right to vote
were withdrawn I I recognize that you
have a fiscal concern around that um if
all everything other than the right to
vote and then the fiscal Appropriations
were made to cover those costs would you
still object to this bill or would that
be um we would have to look at the final
bill not the obviously our biggest
opposition are the safety concerns with
with Firearms um but if we had an
appropriation to cover staff that we
would be able to carry it out then we
would be able to carry it
out questions thank you thank you is
there anyone else wishing to testify on
this bill who hasn't testified on this
bill
already um before I to closing the
public hearing I would like to I'm
appointing a subcommittee on this bill
um representative Stone wheeler Janan
and N are on the subcommittee
representative stones and chair uh two
weeks please on the return thank you and
that includes our business for the
day ston wheeler Jan
new